herr lauterbach eine inzidenz von 584
das erste mal über 100.000
neuinfektionen genauer gesagt
112000 kommt deutschland aktuell besser
oder schlechter durch diese omikron
bälle als gedacht wie schätzen sie das
ein
also bisher kommen wir so gut durch die
welle wie wir so erhoffen konnten wir
haben maßnahmen ergriffen um die im
welle abzudämpfen der grundgedanke ist
ja dass wir hier diese besonders steilen
welle ab wenn es in einer wand quasi in
eine etwas geringer hohe wand oder einen
hügel gar und auf dem weg sind wir wir
haben die verdopplung seit der also
mikrowelle die haben wir verlängern
können von ungefähr zwei zweieinhalb
tagen auf mittlerweile sechseinhalb tage
somit ist es schlimm genug kann grund
zur entwarnung aber die maßnahmen die
ergriffen worden sind wirken und sie
wirken auch ungefähr so stark wie wir
berechnet hat herr lauterbach ich bis
heute gerne mal mit ihnen über zahlen
sprechen das sind beeindruckende zahlen
112.000 neuinfektionen wie kommt man an
diese zahlen welche zahlen sind
sozusagen die bewertungsgrundlage wenn
wir hören im moment dass beispielsweise
das ergebnis eines pcr tests bis zu drei
tagen dauert wo ist die verlässlichkeit
bei diesen zahlen oder leute sich gar
nicht melden wenn sie sich
beispielsweise infiziert haben
also bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt sind die
zahlen relativ verlässlich wir haben
also eine hohe kapazität die wir auch
nutzen wir setzen die pcr kapazität so
ein dass diejenigen die also einen
verdacht auf kohle haben durch ein anti
gen test als die deutschland pcr-test
nachgetestet werden und damit geht man
dann in die statistik ein auf der
anderen seite ist aber auch so wir
werden das nicht durchhalten können wir
werden tatsächlich sofort zahlen
bekommen dass wir die pcs verteilen
müssen priorisieren müssen dafür werde
ich am wochenende einen vorschlag
vorlegen wie das passieren soll also
wäre den pc attest bekommt und wo wir
den pc hat es nicht mehr einsetzen das
werden wir bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am montag
beschließen will die beschlussvorlage
wird aber bis zum wochenende fertig sein
bis dahin also haben wir noch das geld
was ja auch bisher gut funktioniert hat
das heißt jetzt mal ganz konkret gefragt
sitzt jetzt jemand zuhause hat das
gefühl da könnte was sein habe ich mir
möglicherweise angefangen hat erste
symptome der schnelltest der antigen
test ist möglicherweise positiv was soll
er machen soll er beim gesundheitsamt
anrufen macht er das überhaupt
verlässlich nochmal wie verlässlich sind
diese zahlen aber
die zahlen sind das eine zunächst einmal
muss der test stattfinden das ist sehr
wichtig und da kann man sich an die
üblichen so testzentren ländern das
heißt man kann zum hausarzt gehen man
kann so ein testzentrum gehen wo pcr
test gemacht werden das können aber dann
nur solche zentren sein wo auch die
positiven getestet werden können das ist
jetzt keine situation wo man noch mal
einen zweiten anti gentest machen kann
meinetwegen als bürger ist da wird man
nur getestet wenn also kein verdacht auf
ein so positives ergebnis besteht wenn
jemand schon symptome hat oder hat schon
einen positiven test dann muss man zum
pcr-test zentrum oder zur praxis dass
das ist sozusagen die die theorie die
frage ist wer macht das tatsächlich also
wir wären auch gleich bilder aus sachsen
sehen wo sich erkennbar menschen
sozusagen aus diesem system wenn man so
will auch verabschiedet haben und sagen
ist mir wurscht die macht das was ihr da
machen wollt aber ich habe damit schon
lange nichts mehr zu tun die frage ist
wie stellen sie sicher dass die leute
die zu hause sitzen einen positiven
antigen test haben sich dann aber
dennoch nicht beim arzt melden weil sie
keine lust auf quarantäne haben weil es
im zweifel und in kanada verfolgt weiß
keiner überprüfen kann
es geht ja hier nicht ums überprüfen
sondern hier geht es ja um den ganz
normalen bürger der bürger der ein
antigen test macht und er ist positiv
der will doch in der regel wissen bin
ich jetzt erkrankt oder bin ich es nicht
und also dann wird man würde das für
zwei sich also durch einen pcr-test
lassen
was also lag beim einen oder anderen so
sagen dass er es nicht macht aber also
ich glaube nicht dass das eine wirklich
gut unterstützt hypothese ist die
allermeisten die also einen positiven
antigen tester haben die wollen doch
wissen sind sehr krank oder nicht frau
kipping das thema haben sie mutmaßlich
auch wie hoch schätzen sie die
dunkelziffer naja so sehr hoch war die
nicht sein weil viele menschen sicher
mit weil er auch auf arbeit testen
lassen müssen das heißt ja können sich
nicht nur einfach zu hause testen lassen
sondern machen das auch auf arbeit und
dabei sein in einem anderen so dass also
dort auch ein zeuge ist wir haben leute
in den arbeits in den unternehmen
mittlerweile geschult die ausgebildet
worden sind zum testen also auch das
passiert in den schulen wird gemeinsam
getestet die die sie entsprechendes
klassisches dieser schnelltest genau
aber werden die wären da nicht der
statistik wenn ja nicht gewertet
natürlich werden die aufgewertet wir
hatten die situation lauterbach
beschrieben hat ja schon in sachsen wir
hatten ja schon situationen wo die
gesundheitsämter gar nicht mehr alle mit
pcr test testen konnten oder hinterher
gekommen sind irgendwie halt auch der
schnelltest wenn er positiv war als
grundlage für das gesundheitsamt ein
eben eine quarantäne auszusprechen das
hat dann ist das der fall dann über
fragen also weil der also wirklich
sicher der goldstandard ist der pzst
habe ich nochmal die frage nach der
datenlage ist ja geld sagt gerade bei
diesen enormen zahlen die so explodieren
finde ich eine wichtige frage seit wann
gilt dass das auch der antigen
schnelltest wenn er denn positiv ist in
die statistik als fall ein scoop it 19
fall einfließt obwohl er durchaus
unzuverlässigkeiten hat
also wenn er an das gesundheitsamt
gemeldet wird zählt natürlich auch der
anti gen test wir werden jetzt dazu
übergehen ich möchte der also
beschlussvorlage vom wochenende nicht
vorgreifen aber wir arbeiten jetzt also
in einer situation wo wir erstmalig
sogar hingehen werden und diejenigen die
also positiv getestet sind aber nicht
unbedingt den pcr test benötigen dass
wir die quasi über das system melden
aber vom pc hat es sogar abraten weil
wir die pcr test für ganz besondere
maßnahmen benötigen die müssen
priorisiert werden camping hat
vollkommen korrekt beschrieben wenn
einer so antigen test gemacht wird und
würde das gesundheitsamt gemeldet dann
ist er natürlich gültig wenn sie sagen
für besondere maßnahmen besondere fälle
wer kriegt dann in zukunft noch einen
pcr-test
das würde ich einfach jetzt nicht also
alles entwickeln das relativ kompliziert
wir brauchen im prinzip bekommen jetzt
eine sehr schwere bälle rein da brauchen
wir
die in drei bereichen greifen der erste
bereich dass wir brauchen gute
quarantäne und isolations regeln für
diejenigen die kontaktpersonen waren
oder krank sind haben wir daran
gearbeitet letztes wochenende das steht
einigermaßen zweiter punkt also wir
brauchen gute tests regeln dass wir die
pcr test im wesentlichen für diejenigen
verwenden wo wir ganz sicher mit sagen
müssen die sind entweder krank oder sie
sind mittlerweile wieder gesund dafür
kommt die verordnung am wochenende und
zum dritten brauchen wir auch noch also
eine regelung wo wir genau festhalten
wäre es eigentlich genesener und also
wären das gerechnet dann haben wir
insgesamt also ein gutes system okay das
heißt pcr tests für krankenpfleger nehme
ich an für ärzte für polizisten
altenpflege menschen die sozusagen im
weiteren sind systemrelevant sind
wie gesagt ich würde es nicht alles aus
wollen aber ganz klar ist dass hier die
krankenhaus beschäftigten die pflege
beschäftigten die menschen derbe
eingliederungs setzte behindertenpflege
dass die also besonders berücksichtigt
werden müssen und wir müssen
insbesondere auch darauf achten dass
diejenigen die selber krank waren wir
die zurückkommen an diesen arbeitsplatz
und aus der isolation zurückkehren was
sie uns darauf verlassen können dass sie
nicht noch ansteckend sind wir können
diese leute nicht gefährden die
schutzbedürftig sind und da wären wir
großen wert darauf legen sie sie haben
das ja heute auch glaube ich habe nur
gesagt das
gesundheitspersonal dem redaktions
netzwerk deutschland haben sie das
glaube ich gesagt
priorisiert werden soll unter anderem
bei diesem thema noch mal die frage wenn
sie sagen wir kommen da jetzt auf eine
schwere welle zu mit welche
infektionszahlen rechnen sie in den
nächsten tagen wochen
das ist alles sehr wichtige frage ich
habe beim robert-koch-institut
modellierung in den auftrag gegeben die
sich mit der frage also beschäftigen wie
stark wird die welle werden dass dort
sehr vorzügliche modellierungs
arbeitsgruppe mit der ich auch also
anfang an in der vergangenheit gute
erfahrungen gemacht haben und die
sollten quasi ausrechnen wann ist also
der höhepunkt der welle die viele also
fälle erwarten wir auf der
intensivstation also auf den regulären
stationen wie lange das nach und dabei
wird berücksichtigt wie es unsere
impfquote in deutschland wie es die
booster quote was wissen wir
mittlerweile über das omikron virus im
vergleich zum data virus wie lange
dauert es bis man ansteckend ist wie
lange bleibt man steckte und so weiter
und so fort wenn man die realistischen
szenarien zusammen fast wie gesagt da
kann es an ganze bandbreite von
szenarien geben die alle passieren
können also der genau ausgang ist nicht
klar aber wenn man also sagen wir die
realistischen szenarien sich anschaut
das ist nicht gesagt dass die dann
kommen aber die an die größte
wahrscheinlichkeit dann würde ich davon
ausgehen dass die welle mitte februar
ungefähr ihren höhepunkt haben wird und
dass wir dann tatsächlich auch also auf
dem höhepunkt der welle mehrere
hunderttausend fälle also pro tage
warten müssen da wir in deutschland eine
hohe zahl von ungeimpften bei den
älteren haben also kann das bei uns ganz
anders ausgehen als beispielsweise in
italien frankreich oder in england ich
bringe ein beispiel wenn ich die überall
so 50-jährigen heranziehe in england
dann ist die gruppe derer die da noch
ungeimpft sind in der größenordnung von
ein bis zwei prozent
das sind natürlich werte an die wir
nicht herankommen oder ich bin ein
anderes beispiel in england ist die
gruppe derjenigen die drei mal geimpft
sind also gewusst hat sie bei den über
50-jährigen 90 prozent und zwar nicht 90
prozent der geimpften sondern 90 prozent
dieser gesamten altersgruppe das heißt
das sind dann länder die können sehr
hohe fallzahlen verkraften und trotzdem
passiert nicht viel auf der
intensivstation
das sind aber nicht wir sondern wir
haben eben das handicap das manko wenn
man so will die also gefährdung durch
die große zahl derjenigen die uns die
unwillig sind die impfung zu akzeptieren
aber trotzdem voll im risiko stehen das
ist eine besonderheit in deutschland die
sich aus geprägt hat und er mit der
müssen wir halt ringen das wird die
nächsten wochen schwer machen trotzdem
gegenrede wir haben auch in deutschland
eine sinkende
biel niedrige
hospitalisierung von 3,34
das heißt dass man sich aber das ist ja
vollkommen also
ich würde ich hatte sie unterbrochen ja
ich wollte heute sie unter woche wollen
eigentlich nur darauf hinaus wir haben
sehr sehr hohe infektionszahlen über
100.000 steigende zahlen fast
explodierende zahlen infektionszahlen
und trotzdem stabile situation in den
krankenhäusern muss einfach mal so zu
übersetzen
ja das ist aber eine also nicht
relevante oder anders ausgedrückt er
elefanten momentaufnahme die welle läuft
er gerade ist an wir haben ja
begrenzungen also die wirken daher also
ich hatte eben schon auf die verdopplung
sandten abgehoben also werden wir die
richtig starke welle die innen also
england oder in frankreich jetzt schon
läuft 500.000 aus inspektionen am tag
und mehr also dieser welle wird ja in
deutschland noch kommen und dann haben
wir aber dann das sonderproblem das ist
die große gruppe der älteren ungeimpften
trifft somit rechnen wir dann also mit
der tatsächlichen belastung auch der
intensivstationen damit rechne ich aber
nicht jetzt sondern also bisher sind ja
bisher nur wenige infiziert mit
unbekannt und da sind auch noch die
jüngeren altersgruppen die richtige
belastung in den intensivstationen die
würde ich mitte februar ende februar
erwarten das ist noch ein monat hin und
dann so hoffe ich dass es dann noch gut
aussieht das wird ja die belastungsprobe
seien nicht das was wir jetzt in das
sind ja fast nur noch die data fälle die
jetzt hoffentlich bald gesunden diese
diese handbewegung diese machen bei
delta die macht mir macht mir hoffnung
weil sie sagt im grunde dass das ding
verschwindet zumindest deutlich so diese
handbewegung trotzdem noch mal die frage
erlaubt aber wir haben eingangs über
zahlen gesprochen sie modellieren auf
der basis dieser zahlen modellieren sie
diese szenarien andere zahlen haben sie
nicht wir haben gerade erfahren diese
zahlen sind mehr oder weniger
zuverlässig und mit steigenden
infektionsraten werden sie im zweifel
immer unzuverlässiger weil uns schlicht
und ergreifend auch die pcr tests die
kapazitäten auf den gesundheitsämtern
usw ausgehen deswegen noch mal die frage
wie hoch schätzen sie die dunkelziffer
hoch glauben sie ist tatsächlich die
fallzahlen im moment offiziell bei
112000 wo liegt sie mutmaßt nicht
wirklich
also dunkelziffer wird wahrscheinlich
also 100 prozent sein so dass die
tatsächliche zahl der infizierten
ungefähr doppelt so hoch ist aber ich
will auf einen punkt hinaus zahlen und
zahlen müssen unterschieden werden also
die zahlen die so ein modell braucht wie
ich es gerade beschrieben habe ist zum
beispiel also der braucht man nun mal
gemacht haben die haben nichts mit der
die zahlen zu tun also wie viele
infizierte haben wir jetzt im moment
oder wie viele sind schon also infiziert
und sind über den pcr gelaufen was auch
immer wie hoch ist die dunkelziffer das
hat damit nichts zu tun die zahlen die
da hingehen das sind zahlen zum beispiel
wie viele tage dauert es bis jemand da
also sagen mal ansteckend ist nach der
infektion wie lange bleibt der
ansteckend wie lange dauert es bis er
jemanden infiziert hat wenn er
ansteckend war wie stark ist die impf
wirkung im vergleich zur data impfung
wie also hoch ist der prozentsatz der
booster impfung wie lange liegt ein
booster im funk zurück ist das eine
verbesserung oder eine ältere busse ist
die altersverteilung das sind die zahlen
die so in so ein modell hineingehen die
haben aber nichts mit diesen asozialen
einmal also die die zahlen die wir diese
gerade beschrieben haben das ist quasi
die buchhaltung der infektionen die wir
jetzt vorhalten jetzt aber steht diese
buchhaltungs zahlen die sehr wichtig
sind also wie viele sind jetzt krank wie
viele pcs haben wir gemacht jo ist die
dunkelziffer uns vor das sind andere
zahlen als die also dynamischen zahlen
denen so ein modell reingehen womit man
dann zum schluss ausruft ausrechnet was
kommt da auf uns zu okay gut dass wir
das mal auch in der klarheit besprochen
haben weil es wichtig ist dass die leute
das verstehen ich würde gerne weil sie
jetzt schon mehrfach angesprochen haben
die zu niedrige impfquote vor allen
dingen bei über 60 was schätzen sie wo
sie wieder ungefähr bei zehn millionen
menschen oder wie viele sind das
nein so viele sind das nicht also ich
hätte er die größenordnung wir haben da
auch das ist an der zahl die wichtig die
wir wirklich nicht ganz genau haben aber
bei den über 65 jährigen gehe ich von
maximal 3 millionen geimpften aus also
vollkommen ungewiss es kommt aber noch
eine andere gruppe dazu diejenigen die
nur zweimal games sind also kein booster
haben und die auch im risiko stehen
somit also ist das also eine große zahl
denn wenn in dieser gruppe viele
erkranken würden war nicht wegen jeder
dritte dann hätten wir innerhalb von
ganz kurzer zeit eine massive
überlastung der kompletten intensiv
kapazität und müssten also maßnahmen
ergreift okay so wenn die situation so
dramatisch ist wenn wir einfach nicht
auf diese zahlen kommt wenn wir ein ums
andere mal uns gegenseitig versichern
und ankündigen da wird jetzt eine
impfpflicht kommen wir haben jeden abend
das gespräch hier und immer wieder auch
politisch verantwortliche aus der
allerersten reihe die sagen ich hab da
mal der sitz hat meine position geändert
die die lage hat sich verändert ich war
ursprünglich gegen eine impfpflicht ich
bin jetzt deutlich für eine impfpflicht
wann kommt diese impfpflicht und wie
sicher kommt diese impfpflicht
ich bin zunächst mal ein ganz klarer
befürworter einer impfpflicht und man
muss aber zunächst einmal ganz klar
sagen die impfpflicht wird an der jetzt
vor uns liegen das schmale von wellen
nichts mehr verändern können das ist
vorbei aber die impfpflicht also
begründe ich wie folgt also eine
impfpflicht ist unbedingt notwendig wenn
wir dieses problem ein für alle mal
erledigt wissen wollen im herbst ich
möchte einfach nicht nur an der
situation kommen wo wir im herbst erneut
darüber nachdenken müssen müssen wir
locker und maßnahmen erkranken müssen
vielleicht unsere kinder also in den
hybrid unterricht also können bestimmte
geschäfte nicht mehr betrieben werden
ich glaube dass diebe die also menschen
in deutschland die bürger jetzt so lange
so viele opfer gebracht haben diejenigen
die sich an die regeln gehalten haben
diejenigen die sich haben impfen lassen
jetzt ist ehrlich gesagt die pflicht
auch mal da dass diejenigen die wir die
zeit geschützt haben die ungeimpften wir
schützen ja derzeit mit unseren
maßnahmen und auch mit unseren opfern
mit den kindern angefangen wir schützen
die ungeimpften jetzt ist der zeitpunkt
da wo auch die ungeimpften mal ihren
beitrag leisten müssen und das ist aus
meiner sicht die eben pflicht und sie
sollte aus meiner sicht so schnell wie
möglich geschlossen werden so dass sie
im herbst schon voll wirken kann warum
legen sie dann auch als als koalition
nicht einen klaren gesetzesentwurf vor
warum sagt ihr eigener kanzlei und fällt
ihnen sozusagen an der stelle in den
rücken will ich nicht sagen aber nächste
zumindest in einem angedeuteten regen
stehen sagt als abgeordneter werde ich
selbstverständlich für die impfpflicht
stimmen aber trennt sauber zwischen
seinem status als abgeordneten um
bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland ich krieg das in meinem kopf
nichts zusammen man kann doch nicht
sagen wenn ihr jetzt im fernsehen olaf
scholz sieht ist es der abgeordnete und
am nächsten tag ist es wieder der
kanzler so viel schizophrenie kann ich
sein
das ist gar nicht schizophren ist
genauso wie olaf scholz ich würde
einfach erläutert so dass jeder versteht
ich muss ja als
bundesgesundheitsminister allen anträgen
zur impfpflicht zuarbeiten genauso wie
der justizminister also die anträge
müssen ja technisch so von uns
vorbereitet werden dass sie zu gesetzt
sind werden können und wenn sie nachher
gesetze werden müssen das auch umsetzen
und in dieser phase wo die gesetze jetzt
von den abgeordneten kommen müssen wir
neutral sein und diese neutralität die
setzt voraus dass wir nicht selbst
antragsteller sind ich muss zum beispiel
also sein malvorlagen also
gruppenanträge derzeit also verbessern
überprüfen und weiter bringen die also
die impfpflicht ungefähr so umsetzen
würden wie ich mir das auch vorstellen
würde aber auch andere anträge
gruppenanträge mit denen ich also wenig
inhaltliche gemeinsamkeiten haben und
dann sind auch noch anträge darunter
wird die eben pflicht einfach abgelehnt
und damit ich quasi diese neutralität
habe kann ich nicht auf einem antrag
drauf sein sonst würde das bedeuten dass
ich zwar vorgeben muss alle anträge sind
mir gleich wir werden aber wer will mir
das denn glauben wenn ich selbst
antragsteller auf einem antrag bin der
schiedsrichter kann nicht mitspielen das
ist klar wenn man wenn man es so macht
wie sie das jetzt vorhaben jahr kräftig
beobachte sie schon die ganze zeit was
geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie das
hören ich ich habe den den bösen
verdacht dass versteht da draußen kein
mensch diese begründung auch versteht
kein mensch erinnert wir haben hier eine
etwas tatsächlich auch wieder paradoxe
situation einerseits erklärte
gesundheitsminister sehr ausdauernd und
auch nachvollziehbar mit vor welchen
herausforderungen wir stehen in welchem
verstrickungen auch mit welchen
problemen wir es zu tun haben
andererseits ist natürlich völlig üblich
dass eine regierungskoalition eigene
gesetzesvorschläge einbringt und auch
verabschiedet das das ist ein ganz
normaler vorgang in einen in einem
prozessen insofern ich verstehe die
argumentation formal ich halte sie aber
für sehr schwer vermittelbar
und ehrlich gesagt in der dringlichkeit
der situation persönlich nicht
nachvollziehbar obwohl ich das anliegen
durchaus teile
herr lauterbach auch für sie na ja ich
meine setzt seit zwei jahren vertrauen
die leute ihnen sie waren häufig in der
sendung wir haben uns häufig darüber
ausgetauscht wir haben uns mal sehr sehr
kritisch und und mal konstruktive
ausgetauscht und und am ende war immer
das ergebnis da ist einer der das
handwerk versteht der der genau weiß was
zu tun ist und jetzt sagen sie obwohl
ihnen dieses große vertrauen
entgegengebracht wird ich verhalte mich
neutral dass das ist das gegenteil von
führung
das ist ja nicht richtig also zunächst
aber ich bin da nicht neutral also wofür
ich stehe ich habe ja gerade die
begründung der impfpflicht noch einmal
vorgetragen
und habe das im bundesrat getan im
deutschen bundestag getan ich mache das
jeden tag jeder weiß ja dass ich ein
befürworter der impfpflicht bin aber die
frage ist doch also ob die
gesetzesvorlage für die impfpflicht aus
dem bundestag kommt so zum platz von der
regierung und hinauf und bei solchen wie
bei so wichtigen ethik fragen ist es
sehr häufig so dass die also
entscheidung dann
parteiübergreifend ohne fraktionszwang
aus dem bundestag kommt die idee ist
quasi die anträge sollen nach höheren
also so gestaltet sein dass leute von
der npd von der fdp den grünen der cdu
und den linken alle auf dem gleichen
antrag sind das würde ja die anträge
auch stärken wenn sie parteiübergreifend
aus der mitte des bundestages gewonnen
das ist ja bei diesem wichtigen ethik
fragen ist das ja wichtig dass das keine
parteipolitik ist wir wollen ja quasi
die impfpflicht von der parteipolitik
loslösen trotzdem ist es ganz klar wenn
nachher anträge kommen nun jeder weiß
ich bin ein befürworter der impfpflicht
olaf scholz auch dann werden wir uns
natürlich auf einen dieser anträge
wiederfinden sie wollen sich da haben
sie natürlich recht von der
parteipolitik loslösen sie vertrauen
ihrer eigenen koalition nicht sie
vertrauen ihrem eigenen
koalitionspartner der fdp nicht sie
vertrauen dem dem gruppenantrag von
wolfgang kubicki nicht sie haben angst
dass sie irgendwann die kanzler mehrheit
verlieren das ist doch das wahre problem
warum benennt man das nicht mal klar und
sagt wir haben da ein problem in den
eigenen reihen und wir müssen uns da
ehrlich machen jemand wir haben so viel
vertrauen verloren an ganz verschiedenen
stellen kommen später noch mal dazu
warum muss man sich dann an dem punkt
sozusagen das sind rhetorische tricks
das sind nebelkerzen wieder zu hören was
ich doch hören will ist einen kanzler
der von vorne führt der das einlöst was
er selber immer wieder angekündigt hat
wer bei mir führung bestellt der bekommt
sie ich lese ihnen den satz von olaf
scholz zu impfpflicht vor ich zitiere
ich halte die impfpflicht für notwendig
und ich werde mich aktiv dafür einsetzen
also tut mir leid so kann ein normaler
abgeordneter sprechen ein bundeskanzler
dieses landes muss von vorne führen
wachsweich hat kann man es nicht
formulieren werde mich aktiv dafür
einsetzen ist das an
naja bei ethik anträgen also war es auch
in der vergangenheit so dass zum
beispiel angela merkel sich nicht das so
an die spitze der bewegung eines antrags
steht aber ich will etwas anders sagen
was also ich schade finde ich ehrlich
sagen dass wir in deutschland jetzt mehr
darüber sprechen also wer nacht den
antrag also wer ist der antragsteller
für die impfpflicht ist das vielleicht
ein manöver wo man der fdp entgegen
kommt und zweitens dass wir aus einmal
dieser art in meine parteipolitik macht
dass die cdu noch versucht meinetwegen
hier zu sagen da fehlt dem kanzler die
führungsstärke und so weiter also dieses
übliche das ist dass ich sag mal das
palaver um die parteipolitik wer ist
etwas stärker schwächer zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt usw viel wichtiger wäre es
noch dass wir über die inhalte einer
impfpflicht sprechen ich habe zum
beispiel heute mit dem ich habe heute
mit dem italienischen
gesundheitsminister über die impfpflicht
die in italien also eingeführt wird
länger gesprochen das sind einfach
relevante interessante diskussionen dass
noch viel wichtiger was spricht
eigentlich für eine impfpflicht wann sie
kommen in welcher altersgruppe als
darüber zu spekulieren also
wolfgang kubicki vor hat oder was auch
immer aber diese aber diese spekulation
tut mir leid diese spekulationen haben
sie tür und tor geöffnet und zwar genau
mit dieser art zu agieren das ist in der
tat die frage mich würde interessieren
was denkt der bundeskanzler dieses
landes erstens über die impfpflicht
haben wir schon gehört er wird sich
aktiv dafür einsetzen würde dann aber
gerne wissen wie wollen wir das machen
was steht in diesem gesetzesentwurf drin
wie ziehen wir das durch was ist der
große plan also wie würden sie es machen
da weiter machen wenn sie jetzt eine
impfpflicht verordnen könnten wie würden
sie es machen was ist sind sie sie
müssen ja heute abend jetzt hier kein
antrag auslösen aber was wäre die idee
hier erstmal
es wird ja im hintergrund an anträgen
gearbeitet und ich nehme an dass also
erste anträge die auf sag ich einmal aus
der mittel der abgeordneten der ampel
also koalition erlaubt es die in der
lage waren woche beschuldigungen ist
immer schwer weil die distanz dann
bestimmt so viel aber ich hatte gerade
schnellschuss also sie beschäftigen sich
doch mit nichts anderem und diese
regierung beschäftigt sich da auch ganz
zentralen mit genau dieser frage also
schnellschuss ist das nicht sondern sie
müssten doch eine idee davon haben ja
ich das läuft schnellschuss schnell
natürlich habe ich auf jeden fall aber
schnellschuss war jetzt bezogen auf die
gespräche etwas schon dass ich hier den
bürgern vortrage wie ich es machen würde
und zwar so dass das wahr gemacht ich
beschäftige mich in der tat sehr
intensiv damit uns schon lange und haben
bezahlt diesen fragen gedanken gemacht
ich habe mir zum beispiel gedanken
gemacht und nun ab wann sollte die
impfpflicht gelten also kommt die früh-
oder wie lange können wir uns hat das
sollen wir noch mal eine große runde
drehen indem wir leute freiwillig
ansprechen bis wann muss das umgesetzt
sein wie setzen wir zum beispiel fest
womit geimpft wird wie oft musste werden
gedankengut man sich der frage also wie
finde ich heraus wer ist eigentlich
umgehen wie also kontrolliere ich das
und so weiter also all diese dinge das
sind ja schon dreieck also prinzip ist
sie endlich erforderlich dass der erste
punkt des tages dann ist sie geeignet um
das problem zu lösen was da genannt
wurde und ist sie maßvoll aus um in
diesem dreieck da bin ich schon seit
wochen unterwegs und ich bitte um
verständnis dass ich hier nicht in ein
paar minuten dann meine eigenen gedanken
vortragen will und es darum geht es ja
auch gar nicht aber ich glaube dass es
das sehr gute anträge geben wird aus der
mitte des parlaments und ich hoffe dass
die fraktionsübergreifend aus gehör
findet noch mal wenn sie könnten wie sie
wollten ab wann gibt es diese
impfpflicht für wen kommt diese
impfpflicht wie läuft das ab
ich will das auf die schnelle hier nicht
deklinieren ich will nur einen punkt
sagen ein punkt ist mir sehr wichtig
weil der für die bürger hat wichtig ist
also
wofür machen wir das ganze was ich eben
schon gesagt habe wir kommen ohne
impfpflicht aus meiner sicht aus dem
schlamassel nicht heraus wir werden im
herbst wieder problem haben wir müssen
damit rechnen dass es dann so genannte
re kombinierte variant gibt oder geben
könnte wo man quasi die
ansteckungsgefahr einer nikon variante
dann mit der gefährlichkeit
einer delta variante oder ähnlichem
feiernden kombiniert sieht das ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dass halten viele
theologen für denkbar oder finde ich
unwahrscheinlich weil die varianten ja
jetzt nebeneinander existieren ich will
einfach dass wir im herbst soweit sind
dass wir dann einfach sagen können wir
gewinnen unser normales leben zurück und
dann wenn man das will dann muss die
impfpflicht früh kommen da so dass also
quasi die impfungen stattfinden können
wir abschließend wirken können bis ende
sommer so dass im herbst die wirkung
voll da ist das ist sehr wichtig okay
dann haben jetzt die idee davon waren
das laufen soll wir werden gleich bei
frau kipping hören auch mit blick auf
sachsen man kann gesetze machen wenn man
nicht in der lage ist sie durchzusetzen
dann ist es nicht nur so dass sie
wirkungslos sind dann macht man sich als
staatsmann auch lächerlich und verliert
seine glaubwürdigkeit
gibt ja viele leute die sagen so eine
impfpflicht ohne ins register die kann
man gar nicht kontrollieren das wird
nicht funktionieren
boris palmer der bürgermeister von
tübingen hatte interessanten vorschlag
gemacht wird sie gerne fragen wollen wie
sie den finden er sagt jede kommune in
deutschland ist über die bußgeldstelle
und über das einwohnermelderegister in
der lage das umzusetzen das geht
innerhalb weniger wochen auch ohne im
register und er sagt wenn
fdp-politiker oder andere impfgegner
behaupten es sei schwierig eine solche
pflicht umzusetzen dann ist das
vorgeschoben sehen sie das genauso
wie die frage an mich die dann sie jagen
glaube dass wir dann einiges ich glaube
dass wir an ins register nicht benötigen
das davon bin ich überzeugt also dass
ein im register uns hier nicht also
helfen würde nicht benötigt wird dass
wir andere wege führen finden also ich
will aber hier die speziellen also
vorschläge von boris palmer nicht kombi
also nicht kommentieren also so dass
sich scheibchenweise hier also vortrage
was ich mir gut vorstellen könnte das
ist einfach nicht also da das habe ich
nicht vor aber ein impf register glaube
ich hilft uns hier nicht weiter und es
wurde auch viel zu lang
aufzubauen werden dann nachher
probleme mit dem datenschutz
möglicherweise und wir kämen zu spät das
hilft niemandem
und zum schluss würde ich gerne noch
einen punkt bedient ansprechen die
berühmte frage des genesenen status
england österreich frankreich genesen
den status 180 tage man könnte auch
sagen gropp ungefähr sechs monate in der
schweiz sogar möglich bis zu einem jahr
weil die schweiz schweizer
wissenschaftler offensichtlich
erkenntnisse vorliegen haben die sagen
neben immunantwort nach einer infektion
fällt so breit aus dass derjenige
diejenige dies hatte bis zu einem jahr
geschützt sind in deutschland plötzlich
nur noch drei monate ursprünglich sechs
monate plötzlich nur noch drei monate
was
wir gesehen haben dass diejenigen die
zum beispiel mit der data variante
infiziert gewesen sind nach drei monaten
sich schon nach mit der nikon variante
infizieren können das ist einfach es ist
traurig aber so ist das die data
variante und die also omikron variante
sind genetisch also so weit auseinander
dass man von einem unterschiedlichen
serotyp sogar springt spricht und also
diese mutationen die dazwischen liegen
die führen dazu dass man also sich mit
dem einen infizieren kann wenn man das
andere hatte und umgekehrt und somit
also ist dann die ansteckung
wahrscheinlichkeit zu hoch als dass man
sagen kann der genesenen status schützt
weiter vor der infektion ich glaube es
ganz simpel aus derjenige der die dritte
variante hatte und ist genesen kann sich
sehr leicht an der omicron variante
infizieren daher spricht man ja auch von
einer sogenannten escape variante oder
flucht variante so dass diese ansteckung
möglich ist das heißt haben wir in
deutschland eine besondere omikron
variante oder anders gefragt haben
österreicher ein anderes immunsystem
länder gehen also so vor dass sie die
gleiche wissenschaftliche literatur aus
so auswerten und dann eben fragen wie
sicher will man sein und wir haben halt
die situation dass wir beim chinesen
status relativ vorsichtig sein müssen
wir müssen sicher sein
weil wir uns halt eine schwerere welle
von als omikron nicht lassen können in
einer situation wo wie viel zu wenig
booster also geimpfte haben und diese
große gruppe der ungeimpften in allen
altersgruppen daher kann man einfach
hier nicht großzügig sein sondern wir
müssen sehr streng nehmen und streng
genommen ist es so derjenige der also
die also genesung mit delta hinter sich
hatte der herr hat sich drei monate
später kann das ich mit omikron
infizieren kann sich infizieren die
frage ist wie hoch ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines schweren
verlaufs darum geht es doch
nicht unbedingt also derjenige der sich
mit nikon infiziert der markt dann
möglicherweise nicht so schwer erkranken
aber wenn er infiziert ist und infiziert
dann einen älteren um games und dann ist
er möglicherweise derjenige der stirbt
das heißt ich muss das ja zu ende denken
ich kann nicht sagen derjenige der sich
jetzt infiziert ist selbst nicht schwer
krank sondern ich muss ich muss schauen
was bedeutet das für die gesamt welle
und also da reicht es nicht auf
denjenigen zu blicken der sich infiziert
sondern dann muss ich auch bauen denken
was passiert mit all denjenigen die er
infiziert werden wir jetzt eine viel
höhere info hätten dann könnten wir uns
eine deutlich längere spanne für den
genesenen status durchaus leistung okay
und eine eine letzte frage herr
lauterbach
das
klingt nicht wahnsinnig optimistisch was
wir da heute gehört haben der andere
wichtige protagonisten lisa gesamten
krise ist neben ihnen ist ein gewisser
christian drosten mit dem sie natürlich
in einem ständigen austausch stehen der
klingt in den letzten tagen und wochen
deutlich optimistischer sagt wir müssen
dem virus jetzt die tür einen spalt weit
öffnen wir müssen das virus laufen
lassen wie gehen sie damit um auch das
ist ja schwierig in der politischen
kommunikation sie sind sie sind genauso
zu sagen der eine der der der politische
hauptprotagonist unter anderen der
virologische und auf beide hat man
gleichermaßen gehört wenn du jetzt nicht
mehr gleich kommunizieren dann wird es
irgendwann schwierig
naja wir kommunizieren weiter im
gleichklang ich bin mit christian
drosten sehr regelmäßigen austausch fast
täglich und wir verstehen uns gut wir
tauschen uns aus hat beginn der pandemie
also das ist alles gut und christian
drosten hat es ja im
tagesspiegel-interview so beschrieben
wir können uns mehr leisten machen an
den spalt auf wenn wir eine ausreichende
also impfung erreicht haben werden wir
quasi die im handy denn wenn die wenn
die der impfschutz in der bevölkerung
hoch genug ist und dass sich ja ganz
genau so also in dem moment wo der
impfschutz in der bevölkerung hoch genug
ist können wir die tür ein stück weit
öffnen das machen ja jetzt auch die
engländer die eltern das sind jetzt an
dem punkt der impfschutz ist so hoch die
können die tür ein stück weit offen aber
wir sind ja nicht an dem punkt und das
sagt auch nicht christian drosten ich
glaube dass er es genauso gut ich weiß
dass es genau so einschätzt wie ich dass
der impfschutz in der bevölkerung zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt natürlich noch nicht
ausreicht damit wir die tür öffnen das
ist noch nicht möglich das ist das
problem der umgehen